going to gay bars has become predictable
I always know exactly who I'm going to
meet the less boy she's been wearing the
snapback she may look like a social
butterfly she hasn't the slightest clue
when it comes to flirting oh great
there's the happy couple what on earth
are they even doing here we get it
you're in love just get out
there's the ultra femme this girl is in
her element
she is glamorous and this the Alpha also
known as the girl you hate to love her
she has the perfect hair the perfect
style in the perfect charisma this girl
has probably never had to buy her and
drink here comes the tourists
she's the straight guy at the bar her
attempts to blend in will amuse you but
rest assure she'll find a way to get the
attention she's looking for
there's the budge she's watching you
from the pool table don't be fooled by
her skills she is way more intimidated
by her surroundings than you think and
then there's this girl the one who hates
the bar me why am I even here
[Music]
Oh
see you next week Eddie